welcome to Hannity we start tonight with
a Fox News Alert we got massive huge
breaking news surrounding the steel
dossier tonight we will break the hills
John Solomon FISA abuse did occur we've
got confirmation we'll tell you all
about it also coming up Solomon will be
here with the brand-new evidence that
will blow a lot of this wide open also
tonight we are going to begin with the
fake Morel phony selective outrage that
is the swamp Washington DC remember
first it's collusion then it's
obstruction oh now it's racism anything
to just hate Trump every second every
minute every hour of every day
if he cured cancer they'd still hate him
the evolution of the left's anti Trump
rage and psychosis is beyond desperate
and predictable and despicable at the
same time now moments ago the
democratically controlled House of
Representatives voted to condemn
president Trump's love it or leave it
tweets about the for far left radical
socialist congresswoman known now as the
squad especially congresswoman Omar
speaker Pelosi called the President of
the United States a racist on the House
floor but the funny part is it was only
a few days ago when the squad leader
congresswoman the real Speaker of the
House Pelosi speaker in name only
Alexandria Castillo Cortes actually
accused Nancy Pelosi of picking out
people of color and racism don't forget
in March remember those same Democrats
they refused to condemn congresswoman
Omar during a resolution spurred by her
constant vile variant anti-semitic
remarks just take a look at your screen
over there these four radical Congress
women they now run the House of
Representatives and they're in control
pretty much of the 2020 Democratic
presidential candidates Pelosi speaker
and name the only and now the for
radicals two of which are bigoted
anti-semites are now setting the agenda
for the entire Democratic Party now
tonight in just a few minutes after some
news we're going to provide context we
have a special Hannity history lesson
about the Democratic Party their history
with race their rampant hypocrisy their
shameful political
grandstanding on the issue of race and
much more my monologue my history lesson
in just a moment we'll get to it in this
segment